[Musik]
jetzt also Koalitionsfrieden na oder
etwa doch nicht gestritten wird um den
Klimaschutz nicht nur die Grünen fordern
eine strenges Tempolimit wir haben
Corona hinterlässt Spuren auch im
Zusammenleben vier von fünf Beziehungen
sind eigentlich kaputt das sind
spannende Themen über die wir heute hier
sprechen mit spannenden Gästen bei 8:15
Uhr ich freue mich auf Bild politik-chef
Jan Schäfer er hat den
Koalitionsausschuss ganz nah mit
verfolgt er sagt na der Frieden der
täuscht Knackpunkt ist vor allem der
Klimaschutz da ist CDU-Politiker Thomas
Heilmann ganz nah bei den Grünen
erfordert ein sofortiges Tempolimit
Bestsellerautor Thomas Meyer weiß wie
kaputt viele Beziehungen eigentlich sind
sein Rad trennt euch macht euch nicht
ein Leben lang unglücklich feiern Eskens
Chefredakteur von Business Insider hat
einen Appell kein Cent mehr für die und
zettelf ja noch nie haben so viele
Menschen in Deutschland ein Dach über
den Kopf gebraucht der Wohnungsmarkt ist
irgendwie nie und trotzdem sind in
diesem Jahr die Nachfrage nach Eigentum
Hoffnungen zusammengebrochen gegenüber
den Vorjahresmonaten sind im Februar und
Januar Nachfragen für Eigentumswohnungen
um über 40% zurückgegangen das ergab
eine neue Studie von der
Immobilienplattform Immowelt Experten
waren jetzt bereits vor einem Platzen
der Immobilienblase insgesamt naja aber
vielleicht kommt ja jetzt auch die Zeit
für Schnäppchenjäger darüber sprechen
wir jetzt hier in dieser Sendung ja was
sagen uns diese Zahlen die interpretés
du diesen Rückgang welche Gründe siehst
du dafür
wir haben ja schon wenn man auch ins
letzte Jahr schaut immer wieder zahlen
und auch Studien gehabt wonach es eine
Blase irgendwie immer gab bzw mit
sinkenden Preisen gerechnet wird ich
persönlich ehrlicherweise glaube das
nicht so ganz denn ähm die Faktoren
sprechen eigentlich dagegen wir haben
einerseits natürlich steigende Zinsen
das ist richtig aber wir haben auf dem
auf der anderen Seite einen auch leer
gefickten Wohnungsmarkt Leerstandsquoten
die zum Teil unter einem Prozent liegen
wir haben eher Zuzug nach Deutschland
wenn wir an die Ukraine denken wenn man
Flüchtlinge aus anderen Ländern denken
also der der der Bedarf an Wohnraum der
wird in diesem Land eher größer als
kleiner und jetzt sehen wir ja auch dass
viele Bauprojekte gar nicht realisiert
werden aufgrund steigender Kosten und
auch das führt ja eher dazu dass das
Angebot nicht sehr viel größer wird aber
bei steigender Nachfrage und einem nicht
sehr viel größeren Angebot heißt das
automatisch die Preise müssen steigen
und dann hat man eben einmal den
Eindruck dass Häusle bauen das Häuser
kaufen das Häuser erwerben das wird zum
Fest unerreichbaren Traum für viele das
ist leider so Kaufpreise steigen
deswegen wird das Angebot auch Knaller
ich rechne nicht mit sinkenden
Immobilienpreisen hat es ein bisschen in
der Geschichte von Deutschland nie
gegeben es hat in der Geschichte als
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg immer nur
sogenannte rechtstendenzen gegenüber
spricht die Preise sind gleich geblieben
und nicht gestiegen und dann sind sie
wieder gestiegen aber signifikante
Rückgänge im privaten Wohnungsmarkt hat
es nicht gegeben die Eigentumsquote ist
dennoch in Deutschland nicht besonders
hoch nur in der Schweiz herr Meier da
ist sie dann noch niedriger muss man
sagen wir erklären Sie sich das kann man
sich einfach nicht leisten wir sind ein
Volk von Mietern so viel ich weiß und
wir sind dann Volk von Suchenden Mietern
in den letzten 20 Jahren haben sich die
Mieten verdoppelt und das ist ein großes
Thema bei uns denn es gibt
wohnungsnotstand aber eben es ist auch
sehr schwierig was zu finden dass man
überhaupt noch bezahlen kann vor allem
als Familie also in Zürich
Dreizimmerwohnung 3000 Franken da und da
gibt's nichts wer kann sich das denn
noch leisten was bedeutet das alle
ziehen immer weiter raus
es ist vieles wird abgerissen und
diejenigen die da gewohnt haben müssen
woanders hin und Leute kommen rein die
deutlich mehr verdienen wir sehen es
auch in Deutschland ganz klar die
Inflation die Lebensmittelpreise um 27
Prozent dann noch mal rauf man fragt
sich wie viel kann man sich noch leisten
man fragt sich aber auch droht da so
eine richtige armutswelle die jetzt ins
Rollen kommt also ich glaube man muss
ein bisschen unterscheiden auch gerade
bei den Immobilienpreisen du hast es
natürlich in der Großstadt in begehrten
Standorten da wird das weiter hochgehen
da glaube ich auch nicht dass die runter
gehen auf dem Lande sieht das z.B ganz
anders aus da gibt es Gegenden wo die
Preise massiv gefallen sind und wo es
wirklich auch schwierig ist überhaupt
ein Haus zu verkaufen also hast eine
totale statt landschere und insbesondere
auch in den attraktiven Standorten in
Rhein-Main Gebiet Düsseldorf Köln
München ist ja absurd was da teilweise
abläuft du hast ja auf der einen Seite
jetzt diese US-Konzerne die da hingehen
mit Google und Apple die da
riesenstandorte aufbauen ist natürlich
eine tolle Nachricht für den Standort
München auf der anderen Seite
explodieren jetzt dort die Mietpreise
und gleichzeitig die Menschen auch
zutiefst verunsichert sie denken sich
wie muss ich dämmen was ist mit der
Wärmepumpe kommt daher auch diese Kauf
Zurückhaltung dass man überhaupt gar
nicht mehr dahin kommt zu sagen man
erfüllt sich mit aller Kraft diesen
Traum vom Häusle bauen naja ich glaube
das einfach von 0% Zinsen auf 4% Zinsen
mit eher steigender Tendenz und einer
Zurückhaltung der Banken zu finanzieren
viele Leute sich einfach die geforderten
Kaufpreise nicht leisten können oder
auch nicht leisten wollen muss sagen
warum ist die Eigentumswohnung in der
Schweiz und in Deutschland so niedrig
das liegt natürlich an der Sicherheit
des Mieters also ich fliege hier nicht
raus wenn ich die Miete bezahle das ist
in Amerika anders das ist in Spanien
anders das in Italien anders das heißt
wenn ich da sicher irgendwo wohnen
bleiben will dann muss ich kaufen und
deswegen sind die Leute viel stärker
gezwungen in den Kauf zu gehen deswegen
sind ist kann man da auch das nicht so
genau vergleichen deswegen ist die
Schweiz noch stärker aber Deutschland
eigentlich auch gerade in den Städten im
Mietermarkt und wird auch bleiben aber
wie bewerten sie auch die Verunsicherung
und schreiben auch viele Menschen hier
die send ung verfolgen ich muss jetzt
ich habe mein Leben lang von Haus
gearbeitet jetzt haben wir unsere
Häuschen wir wollen unser Lebensabend
genießen aber jetzt kommt ich muss
dämmen ich brauche die Wärmepumpe ich
muss auf die Energie schauen die Preise
sind aber gleichzeitig teurer geworden
und plötzlich muss ich 160 000 € in etwa
aufbringen da müssen sie auch schon
ziemlich Palast haben wenn sie 160 000 €
teuer da braucht man ein großes
Grundstück hat mir jemanden hier in der
Sendung der hat ein großes Grundstücken
kleines Häuschen Grundsteuer ist ja eine
Erhöhung die durch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gekommen ist
weil wir eine weil wir die Wohnung oder
die Häuser niedriger bewertet haben als
andere ist jetzt und das hat das
Verfassungsgericht für
Verfassungsgericht ist eine anderes
Thema aber jetzt beim Thema Heizung
wobei ganz kurz auch da die Erhöhung
kommt durch die Kommunen zustande es
geht nur um die Berechnungsgrundlage die
Kommunen hätten die Möglichkeit die
hebelsätze natürlich zu senken und es
machen das aufkommst neutral Zimmer da
bin ich gespannt welche Kommunen das
macht das glaube ich bis heute nicht
bevor es nicht da ist also es heißt
nicht dass es teurer werden muss es ist
immer nennt in der Politik natürlich zu
sagen wir versuchen das irgendwie teurer
zu machen weil es einfach ist die Bürger
abzukassieren aber das
Verfassungsgericht hat nicht gesagt das
ist teuer werden muss ich glaube schon
dass diese Verunsicherung bei den
Hausbesitzern gerade bei den älteren
momentan extrem ist also es ist diese
grundsteuergeschichte gab da rief meine
über 80-jährige Mutter an und war mit
diesen ganzen Ablauf völlig überfordert
und jetzt fragt sie sich was muss ich
jetzt mit meiner Heizung machen also die
Kommunikation die dort auch momentan von
der Regierung stattfindet die ich glaube
die überfordert viele Menschen total und
da gibt's ja auch Stimmen die sagen
einfach
ausziehen in eine kleinere Wohnung
vielleicht weiter nach draußen es macht
was mit Menschen
ja aber bei das ist ja dann bei den
bestandsmietern so dass man rauszieht es
ist eine Schwierigkeit gerade auf dem
Land wo ich keine Fernwärme bekomme etc
nicht meine Heizung umbaue die richtige
Lösung sind lokale nahwärmesysteme das
muss aber die Kommunalpolitik umsetzen
und das kennen dazu wenige aber das wäre
eigentlich die richtige Lösung mit
erneuerbaren Energien und kommunalen
werbeplänen dass ich als Eigentümer weiß
okay in sieben Jahren kommt eine
Wärmeleitung vorbei und dann kann ich so
lange natürlich meine alte Heizung
behalten
dass wir die richtige Lösung soweit sind
wir aber in Deutschland in vielen
Stellen es geht natürlich auch im
Eigentümer nicht nur Mieter sondern es
geht um
ümer Sie diese Kosten
und die
natürlich leben müssen dass sie ihr Haus
und für ganz viele ist das so ich bau
mir das ein Leben lang auf und damit bin
ich sicher zumindest gedanklich mit
diesem Spiel im Kopf sich auseinander
finden auseinandersetzen müssen Sie
dieses Haus verlassen müssen verkaufen
müssen also ich denke das nicht also das
ist leider einige fürchten ja aber man
kann sie glaube ich beruhigen ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass wir keine
Lösung bekommen bei dir wenn ich
sozialverträglich das für alle irgendwie
leistbar machen der
Bundesregierung aber irgendwie auch die
Politik in dieser Sendung deswegen bin
sozusagen dann dürfen wir die
Zuschriften darf ich Ihnen die direkt
weiterleiten
Oppositionspartei bin mit den
Beschlüssen nicht zufrieden die die
Regierung gemacht hat sie dürfen Sie
gerne weiterleiten wo ich kann das
Problem leider nicht lösen aber noch mal
die auch Olaf Scholz heute im Deutschen
Bundestag hat versprochen keiner wird
alleine gelassen das heißt jeder
Eigentümer jetzt wollen wir mal gucken
dass die das Versprechen noch einlösen
wir werden etwas drauf achten gut sie
haben ein Auge drauf herr Meyer wir
reden ja hier gleich noch in der Sendung
über so ein paar Träume die vielleicht
platzen können was glauben Sie was macht
das mit Menschen wenn man sich so ein
Lebenstraum aufbaut und die Gefahr die
Sorgen werden unterschiedlich jetzt hier
in den Tisch eingeschätzt wenn man sich
so ein Haus Traum erfüllt mir viel viel
Arbeit und dann sitzt man für den Kosten
raten Sie dazu so einer ich sag mal
Rationalität wird schon alles gut werden
schaffen wir schon oder wie sehen Sie
das sie haben auch eine Kolumne die
heißt ich hole jetzt ihren Ratschlag
auch ja habe ich tatsächlich
glücklicherweise ist es sind die Fragen
die da reinkommen nicht von solcher
Komplexität ich kann hier nur mutmaßen
grundsätzlich ist Wohnen ein
das Recht das ist ja was wirklich
fundamentales wortwörtlich und wenn da
dran gerüttelt wird aus welcher Richtung
auch immer dann dann erzeugt das
Unwohlsein und Angst also ich spreche
immer wieder mit Leuten und die hätten
eigentlich das Geld aber diese Mieter
Angst die wir die wir hier spüren gerade
in der Schweiz die ist doch beträchtlich
kann ich die Wohnung behalten wenn ich
Streit habe mit einem Nachbarn bringt
überhaupt was zu suchen kann ich mir das
dann leisten und das das geht schon ans
Eingemachte das ist nicht das Auto oder
der Job das ist das Leben zu Hause
dort wo man eben lebt viele Menschen ja
sind mit der Politik unzufrieden und man
hat jetzt auch in den letzten Tagen auch
langen langen Stunden gemerkt dass das
auch durchaus Auswirkungen auf die
Koalition hat dann haben sie sich am
Ende nach einem Marathon muss man sagen
irgendwie geeinigt du aber du traust
diesen Frieden nicht so ganz das ist
jetzt dein Thema in dieser Welt
in der Tat nicht denn wenn Ampel Partner
wenn Koalitionspartner insgesamt drei
Tage zusammen sitzen müssen um Dinge zu
beschließen die zum Teil schon im
Koalitionsvertrag eigentlich standen ein
bisschen aufgeschoben waren aber sich
eigentlich über 30 Stunden nicht so
richtig einigen können dann sagt das
sehr sehr viel über ein Bündnis aus und
es hat in dem Fall ja auch viel
ausgesagt man hat sich noch einmal
zusammengerauft nach einer 30-stündigen
Marathon Sitzung rote grüne und gelbe
ich glaube aber dass das Fundament der
Ampel mittlerweile so bröselig ist wie
Ostsee Sand und ähm die Stimmung im
Bündnis so schlecht wie nie zuvor
Friedrich Merz sollte sich darauf
vorbereiten zumindest in der Lage zu
sein wenn es zu einem Tag X kommt in
diesem Land Bundeskanzler zu werden
was glaubst du wie tief du hast das ganz
nah verfolgt in diesen letzten
vergangenen Stunden wie tief ist der
Graben in der Koalition wirklich was
ging da ab hinter den Kulissen der
Graben ist nach allem was wir hören was
ich gehört habe extrem tief niemand
traut eigentlich dem anderen mehr so
richtig über den Weg das wird alles weg
moderiert von einem Bundeskanzler der
das Wort sehr sehr mittlerweile so
strapaziert dass er zum Teil dreimal das
Wort sehr sagt wie gut die Ergebnisse
sind wie gut die Stimmung in der Ampel
ist aber nach allem was man ja auch
zwischen den Zeilen hört und was wir so
mitbekommen an Gesprächen die geführt
werden gibt es vor allem zwischen SPD
und also oder anders zwischen FDP und
Grünen sehr sehr viel
Kommunikationsprobleme Streit ganz klar
und ähm es gibt auch zwischen SPD und
FDP natürlich Reiberein es gibt zwischen
SPD und Grünen auch einfach rein aber am
Ende stehen sich grüne und SPD immer
noch ein bisschen näher in vielen Dingen
als der mit der FDP und in diesem diesen
30 Stunden hat halt irgendwie jeder auch
mit jedem und auch gegen jeden gekämpft
die Grünen fühlen sich einmal mehr als
Verlierer die FDP als Sieger und ein
Kernproblem ist muss man auch sagen in
dieser Koalition ist das Olaf Scholz der
Bundeskanzler mit Christian Lindner
sprechen kann der ist Finanzministerin
FDP-Chef und die FDP so strukturiert
dass das was Lindner sagt in der Regel
dann auch als Wort Machtwort verstanden
wird bei den Grünen ist das völlig
anders wenn Olaf Scholz mit Robert habe
kommuniziert dann kommuniziert er
wirklich nur mit Robert habe aber er
kommuniziert nicht mit der Parteispitze
und schon gar nicht mit der
Fraktionsspitze und das führt dazu auch
in diesen 30 Stunden wieder das es immer
wieder Gesprächsrunden Gesprächsbedarf
bei den Grünen gibt weil man sich nicht
einig ist weil Robert habe ich nicht die
Prokura hat für die Partei zu sprechen
und das macht natürlich so ein Bündnis
extrem schwierig und ich weiß nicht wie
lange die Minister posten und das Geld
und der Dienstwagen dieses Bündnis dann
am Ende noch zusammenschweißt ganz klar
ist auf jeden Fall die Grünen die
mussten ordentlich Federn lassen ne kann
man sagen wir schon einmal gemeinsam
ich will ganz ehrlich sein reicht das
was du beim Klimaschutz drin steht nein
vor allem beim Verkehr bleibt eine große
Lücke wenn es um die Edition von CO2
geht gleichzeitig sind da Fortschritte
drin ja und deshalb sind wir am Ende
diesen Weg gegangen zu sagen statt dass
es einen Rückschritt kriegt beim
Klimaschutz kämpfen wir für mehr mit
Klimaschutz innerhalb dieser Koalition
oft tun wir es ehrlich gesagt auch
ziemlich alleine und wir werden auch
weiter kämpfen oft sind wir da ziemlich
alleine Herr Heilmann sagt Ricarda
langer und ihr Partei Kollege Jens Spahn
er hat im übrigen nach dem Verhandlungen
eine Jamaika Fahne getwittert ist das
eine einzelung oder glauben Sie der
Stösser bei ihnen in der Partei auf
ordentlich Unterstützung
naja also der Streit zwischen FDP und
Grünen wird ja nicht aufgelöst wenn die
jetzt die SPD rauswerfen die CDU nehmen
dann bleibt diese positionsunterschiede
auch und die Ricarda lang hat Recht
die FDP hat sich durchgesetzt wird immer
Verkehr sie verletzen nach wie vor das
Klimaschutzgesetz das Verfassungsgericht
für
eine verfassungspflicht eingestuft hat
das ist schon ziemlich keine Löser
Vorgang und am Ende des Tages weichen
sich jetzt das Klimaschutzgesetz auf
dass dem die Grünen im Bundestag durch
zustimmen werden also wir werden nämlich
zustimmen kann ich sagen und dass wir
jetzt die Grünen sozusagen vom
Klimaschutz überholen das hätte ich mir
auch nicht träumen lassen aber so geht
es ja nicht wir können doch nicht sagen
die Erde werden muss ist egal wir machen
das nicht die FDP ist einfach nur
Debatte und das was Frau langsack ist ja
oberscheinheilig Frau lang ist
Vorsitzender einer Partei die wirklich
ein ernstes Jahr gesagt dass sie müsste
jetzt alle Kernkraftwerke die noch am
Netz sind abscheiden und gleichzeitig
Kohlekraftwerke hochzufahren also was
verschleudert und verschmutzt die die
Atmosphäre und die Luft jetzt noch
stärker als Kohlekraftwerke das frag ich
auch sie also man kann ja nicht sich
beschweren darüber dass der
Verkehrssektor nicht seine CO2 Ziele
erfüllt und gleichzeitig aber sagen wir
müssen jetzt alles hochfahren was CO2
rausschmeißt nur damit wir die Kernkraft
die nahezu CO2 neutral ist runterfahren
also deswegen da tragen sie auch nach
Athen also
häufig genug wahrscheinlich tragen also
natürlich dieses absolut idiotisch jetzt
mehr Kohlekraftwerke laufen zu lassen
statt die vorhandenen Atomkraftwerke
länger laufen zu lassen das ist Unsinn
so aber da darum ging es ja jetzt in
diesem Gipfel oder in diesem
Koalitionsverhandlungen nicht sondern da
ging sondern im Bereich Verkehr und im
Bereich der Verkehr ist der einzige
Bereich der nicht sinkt trotz der Kohle
jetzt frage ich aber sehr gesinken die
CO2-Emissionen bei Energie bei weil wir
da im Weiterkommen bei Verkehr eben
nicht und
das wird jetzt auch noch sozusagen
abgesegnet mit diesem Beschluss
und dann hat heute herr Scholz gesagt
naja wir werden mehr Klimaschutz im
Gesetz haben obwohl wir die sektorziele
bei Verkehr aufweichen wie das aufgehen
soll ist mir schleierhaft und dann
wollte ich insofern stimme ich ihn dazu
dann feiern die Grünen als Erfolg dass
wir jetzt wieder 15 Milliarden Euro die
schon zu cdu-zeiten für die
Infrastruktur der Bahn ausgeben die
Ampel hatte ist auf 8,9 gesenkt also um
6 Milliarden pro Jahr und die werden es
wieder aufgefüllt ist doch gar kein
Fortschritte die haben einfach nur die
Kürzung zurückgenommen also da ist sehr
wenig wirklich Fortschritt zu sehen
bedeutet
das erklären es
immer nein ich habe verschiedene
eindeutige Antwort von Ihnen bekommen ob
das ob ich einzelne Wunsch ist also ich
würde mir natürlich auch wünschen dass
die CDU wieder regiert wenn natürlich
auch super für Deutschland wenn
CDU-Politiker
die die Konflikte zwischen FDP und Grüne
die ja auch mit uns genauso in derselben
Regierung setzen werden natürlich nicht
aufgehoben nur weil wir einen besseren
Moderator hätten also Angela Merkel hat
schwierige Phasen anders moderiert als
das Olaf Scholz sucht das hat er immer
keine drin
die Ampel auseinanderbricht was ich noch
nicht so schnell glaube aber wenn sie
auseinanderbricht wird's Neuwahlen in
Deutschland geben muss man mal klar
sagen der wird glaube ich keine andere
Kollektion geben sie sich wen würden Sie
sich denn wünschen wenn Sie glauben dass
das eine schwarz grüne Regierung in
Deutschland schneller voran käme wir
würden natürlich genauso wie wie darauf
achten dass jetzt etwa bei den
heizungsbeschlüssen die soziale Balance
gewahrt wird dass wir dann die Aufgabe
der CDU ähm aber ich glaube wir müssen
etwas für die gegen die Erderwärmung tun
denn das nicht zu tun ist das teuerste
für die Bürger was man machen kann warum
haben wir jetzt Inflation Staatsschulden
haben aber ich verstehe
und wenn wir wenn wir das weiß ich gar
nicht aber die die und wenn wir jetzt
das alles vertagen dann wird es
hinterher nur teurer aber wenn es mir
den Grünen so schwierig ist wieso will
dann die CD unbedingt verstehe ich gar
nicht also Klimaschutz das habe ich ja
in allen Parteiprogramm gesehen da
gibt's unterschiedliche Schattierungen
und ähm es gibt unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen wie man die Dinge umsetzt
aber eindeutig erkennen wir doch beim
Thema Klimaschutz tun sich was die
Umsetzung angeht wenn man es mit anderen
Parteien macht die Grünen am schwersten
wenn man an den Markt in gewisser Weise
auch glaubt tun sich die Gründe auch am
schwersten die hätten sie am liebsten
stringent durchregiert von oben Verbote
alles per Strom nicht technologieoffen
so und das ist die Marschrichtung der
grüne rein wie die CDU oder die FDP oder
auch die SPD die das nicht ganz so
strikt sehen deswegen sind das ja keine
schlechteren klimaschütze also noch mal
die Frage warum ausgerechnet mit der
Partei die ist am kompliziertesten macht
weil ich glaube dass die SPD die ja am
längsten in Deutschland den letzten 30
Jahren regiert hat man denkt ja was war
die CDU stimmt aber nicht die SPD hat
länger regiert
aber die
die es gibt nur eine einzige
Legislaturperiode nämlich die eine mit
der FDP die die Union gemacht hat sonst
war die SPD immer in der Regierung
deswegen glaube ich dass man da
weiterkommt aber ich bin ja ihre Meinung
ich bin ja in der CDU nicht bei den
Grünen wir müssen also wir dürfen auf
keinen Fall beim Klimaschutz einfach
nichts tun aber wir sollten es unbedingt
marktwirtschaftlich tun und nicht statt
die registisch und das ist der große
Kinder zu befragen das Stichwort neue
Wahlen da wird ein bisschen jetzt rum
spekuliert für wie wahrscheinlich halten
sie das oder anders gefragt wie
wahrscheinlich halten Sie dass die
Koalition stabil bleibt bis zum Ende der
Legislaturperiode also ich glaube jetzt
nicht dass es so schnell auseinander
geht weil natürlich auch alle sich jetzt
an ihre Posten Klammern das ist ja das
normale Spiel ich habe mir jetzt vor der
Sendung noch mal diese 16 Seiten
durchgelesen und war wirklich
erschrocken dass man nach so einer
langen stundenlanger Sitzung denkt man
ja so jetzt kommt irgendwie was ganz
tolles was so ein Aufbruch für
Deutschland signalisiert so eine tolle
leuchtturmgeschichte eine tolle Idee und
dann kämpft man sich wirklich durch
diese 16 Seiten Geschwurbel durch einer
sagte vorhin das sein 16 Seiten Blabla
und das finde ich eigentlich eine
verheerende Signal was natürlich auch
wieder die Leute dazu führt dass sie
sagen was machen die denn da eigentlich
in Berlin diese Kluft geht dann
natürlich viel weiter auseinander und
wenn man sich diese 16 Seiten durchguckt
und dann hat man natürlich das Gefühl
das ist Saft und kraftlos was diese
Regierung macht trotzdem glaube ich
nicht dass sie so schnell auseinander
geht ich fand interessant was er einmal
gesagt hat dass er sich als
CDU-Politiker eigentlich den Grünen viel
mehr fühlt als der FDP das war ja auch
mal anders ne
die das war mal anders das ist gebrochen
2017 als Lindner da kannst ja bis heute
inhaltlich nicht begründen gesagt hat
lieber nicht regieren als schlecht
regieren jetzt regierter schlecht also
was da also das war einfach unlogisch
und das hat in der Union auch in der CSU
übrigens zu großen nachdenkenprozessen
geführt und muss klar zu sagen wir
unterscheiden uns von den Grünen in
vielen Leitung
wir sollten klarere Ziele formulieren
die auch verlässlicher für die Menschen
und die Wirtschaft kommunizieren aber
den Lösungsweg in die Leute selber
finden lassen und mich irgendwie bis ins
Detail vorgeben dass ich obwohl ich
jetzt eine Biogasanlage schon habe aber
wenn mein Haus umgebaut wird und das
rechtlichen Neubau wird dann muss ich
die abkleben aus der Bibel
näher da kommen wir nämlich gleich auch
noch richtig dazu ich möchte einmal den
Blick auch von außen quasi dazu holen
herr Meyer wenn Sie uns so reden hören
wirklich ich beneidet Deutschland um
diese farbige lebhafte Politik
und ich beneide Deutschland darum dass
es möglich ist dass die grünen Teil der
Regierung sein können das ist bei uns
absolut unvorstellbar trotzdem wird
gerade bei uns immer wieder von der
grünen Diktatur gesprochen wir haben ja
den Bundesrat die meisten wissen dass
dem sieben Menschen angehören aber
niemand kann die aufzählen weil es auch
wirklich nicht eine besondere Rolle
spielt die tun aber jedes mal so als
ging es jetzt darum Leben und Tod bei
den Wahlen sehr interessant und wenn ich
ihn so zuhöre dann tue ich das
mit Neid muss ich offen sagen ich
wundere mich ein bisschen über Sie Herr
Heilmann weil wenn man sich
wählerprofile anschaut ziemlich klar ist
wo das Milieu für CDU wieder liegt da
gibt es die meisten Überschneidungen mit
der FDP da braucht man gar nicht
drumherum zu reden also die Faszination
vieler CDU-Politiker auch von ihnen zu
den Grünen aus welcher aus welchem Grund
die auch kommt die fällt mir immer
wieder schwer zu glauben also wenn man
an die soziale Marktwirtschaft glaubt
wie ist die CDU ja tut zumindest sagt
sie ist immer die FDP tut das auch die
Grünen tun es nicht die sagen es war sie
tun es aber nicht keine
marktwirtschaftliche Partei ist eine
dirigistische Partei da sind Sie ja
schon in den Grundfesten völlig
unterschiedlich also die Ausgangspunkte
sind völlig andere und wir sehen ja auch
in den Koalitionen da sehen wir eine
Ampel jetzt auch aber auch eine
Koalitionen auf Landesebene schwarze und
grüne kommen ja oft gar nicht voran aber
natürlich vertagen problemlos wissen Sie
noch viel besser als ich vertragen
Probleme in Kommissionen dann werden die
Termine so gelegt dass man daran einigen
wir uns danach und am Ende bezahlt der
Steuerzahler das ist natürlich auch gut
klar so kann ich immer machen die nicht
sagen ich mache Projekte damit schwarze
und grün sich wohlfühlen und lasse die
Kosten dem Steuerzahler auf
jeder Hinsicht Kondition keinem von mir
sein die Meinungsforscher sind da ganz
klar wie die wie die Überschneidung
nochmal die Koalition von Boris rein in
Hessen von Hendrik wüst im
Nordrhein-Westfalen von Daniel Günther
in Schleswig-Holstein funktionieren viel
besser als die große Koalition im Bund
als als Hessen die Hessen die die
hessische CDU hat das schlechteste
Wahlergebnis aller Zeiten eingefahren
seitdem sie den Grünen regiert das muss
ihnen doch zu denken
wir gehen jetzt wieder zurück auf die
Bundesebene denn dass ich gerade gesagt
du wunderst dich 5% Punkte gewinnen
5%. also ich finde wir sollten die
Bürger die Wahrheit sagen wir wir werden
alle Bereiche müssen CO2 reduzieren weil
sonst die Erderwärmung auch in
Deutschland viel schlimmer wird so jetzt
können wir oder wie die FDP sagen wir
machen das mit Emissionshandel das
bedeutet wir Benzinpreis wird sehr
schnell Richtung 45 Euro gehen das wird
die FDP gar nicht machen weil sie ja
schon bei viel geringerer Höhe den
Tankrabatt eingeführt hat und den die
Erhöhung des Emissionshandels zum ersten
Januar gegen unseren Widerstand übrigens
gestoppt hat und wenn wir also was
erreichen wollen was nicht mehr kostet
dann sollten wir zumindestens mal
ausprobieren ob wir nicht ein Tempolimit
auf Autobahn haben wir sind das letzte
Land in der Welt die das nicht haben
es wird paar Millionen Tonnen CO2
einsparen wie viel genau würde man ja da
mal genau messen können und außerdem
könnte man sagen Autos müssen kein
Tempolimit kriegen weil wir brauchen ja
kein CO2 beim Fahren so dass wir sogar
noch mal ohne dass es was kostet der
Steuerzahler dann Anreiz geben
so schnell fahren wie sie wollen und die
Verbrenner sollen dann ausgebremst
werden und damit spart man CO2 glaubst
du das ja wissen Sie eigentlich wie viel
Tempolimit ist auf Deutschland Autobahn
gibt der würde die Frage wie viel wie
viel Autobahnkilometer sind ungefähr ein
Drittel der Autobahn
[Musik]
ein Drittel der Autobahn hat
dauerhafte Temperatur
oder weniger als ein Drittel haben
Baustellen dann temporär ja so und dann
so aber ja wenn wir durch Bayern fahren
als beispielsweise wenn wir durch Bayern
fahren Markus Süder stellt sich immerhin
gegen Tempolimit fahren Sie doch mit dem
Auto durch Bayern fahren Sie die
verschiedenen Autobahnen lang sie werden
ganz häufig sogar Tempolimit von 100
haben 100 123 kleiner ist doch der ist
doch die Einschränkung also um das
Argument mal umzudrehen wenn es gar
nicht umso geringer ist doch der Effekt
das heißt wir haben ein Problem mit und
wissen sie studieren gibt die kleinste
sagt 3 Millionen Tonnen die Größe gesagt
ach was
Studien vom Umweltbundesamt die jedes
Jahr jedes Jahr neu seit sechs Jahren
macht das Umweltbundesamt jedes Jahr
eine neue Studie immer neue Ergebnisse
aber ich habe gesagt lass uns das drei
Jahre machen und genau messen dann
wissen wir es doch und was schadet jetzt
eigentlich und wir drei Jahre auf diesem
wenigen recht Kilometern wie sie sagen
so wenig sind gar nicht aber ist egal
ausprobieren und dann messen und dann
wissen
auf 100 gehen dann 120 gesagt aber
bisher haben wir überhaupt gar kein
Tempolimit und dann haben wir ja aber es
ist 70 % der Autobahn aber dann gehen
wir sozusagen als Autoland Deutschland
na wo so viel abhängt von der
Autoindustrie geht dann auf ein
Tempolimit runter wo wir dann plötzlich
die langsamsten Autos Autobahnen in ganz
Europa haben weil ich will das 120
zweitens die die Auto Vorstände die das
früher vertreten haben vertreten das
heute gar nicht mehr weil der drin
nämlich zum automatisierten fahren gehen
und wenn Sie das Auto selber fährt dann
schaffen Sie die hohen Temperatur gar
nicht weil weil
natürlich ehrlich gesagt selten Autobahn
weil ich lieber Zug fahre und in Berlin
selber aber jeder der Tempo mit will
kann das doch machen also auf den
Strecken wo sowieso schon tempoli also
die Frage ist ja nicht fahren Sie doch
einfach langsamer Problem
CO2 das kann ich machen aber selbst
entscheiden
die Erderwärmung fragt nach ausstoßen
wenn wir die Erderwärmung reduzieren
wollen und der Verkehrssektor muss was
beitragen dann haben Sie die Wahl
zwischen höheren Spritpreisen und
Tempolimit ich will entscheiden
beispielsweise auf 140 und Deutschland
würde dann runter also das Italien
erhöht ist noch lange nicht ausgemacht
zweitens der reden wir dann immer zehn
Kilometer Tempo Unterschied ich weiß gar
nicht warum das in Deutschland so ein
emotionales Thema ist das ist ehrlich
gesagt wie beim Rauchverbot ja also ich
kann mich noch erinnern als die Leute
sich in Berlin demonstriert haben weil
sie nur noch auf dem oberen Deck des
Doppeldeckers raus
die durchschnittliche Fahrt das
Fahrtempo auf Autobahn ist wissen sie
dass der das ist unter 100 aber das weiß
ich schon vier habe ich heute noch mal
extra vor der Sendung nach mehrere 104
aber wir sind unter dem tempoli mit
ohnehin schon ja aber
nein
nicht mehr
aber die Schweizer kommen auch gerne auf
die deutsche Autobahn und geben da mal
Gas oder das tun sie ganz gern es gab ja
uns bei uns auch mal die autopartei die
freie Fahrt für freie Bürger forderte
aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat die sich
nicht durchgesetzt bzw in die SVP
verwandelt
es wundert mich dass wir im Tempolimit
haben und dass das doch mehrheitlich gut
eingehalten wird und ich finde es auch
richtig und ich begrüße diesen Vorschlag
also bei Ihnen auch langsam unterwegs
auch gestern über den
koalitionsauszuschuss gesprochen da
wurde einiges kassiert vor allem Robert
Habeck Pläne wird das Ganze jetzt wird
kann er das nicht ganz umsetzen dann
lagern wir es ihm um auf den Verkehr und
ist das auch so ein Geschachere was dann
gemacht wird damit man dort eben die
Einsparungen die Grünen Ideen
verwirklichen kann erstaunlich wie sie
so nah jetzt immer näher an die Grünen
herangehen jetzt auch mit dem Tempolimit
also diese unterschreiten ja quasi auch
die Forderungen
Position
erstaunlich wie sie sich da so in ihren
Wunsch Ihren Wunschpartner derzeit
hinbewegen also ich glaube dass diese
ganze verbotsgeschichte
entspricht nicht meinem Naturell
deswegen bin ich die dagegen dass man
den Leuten irgendetwas vorschreibt und
es gibt ja schon sehr viele
Einschränkungen
ich bin dafür dass die Leute entscheiden
sollen wie sie waren und wenn sie wenn
sie schneller CO2 verbrauchen was wir
hier tun aber da brauchen wir mehr CO2
ich finde auch diesen diesen Aspekt mit
der Autoindustrie wirklichen wichtige
Geschichte und sie halten
wenn sie keine höheren Spritpreise und
kein Tempolimit wollen dann frage ich
nicht wie wollen Sie das denn machen
ich glaube man kann nicht ins Wasser
springen oder was zu reden
natürlich total viele Ideen man kann
sich an diesem Tempolimit ähm was auch
immer das einspart eine Million Tonnen
CO2 1,5 man muss wahrscheinlich jedes
Jahr die neue Umweltbundesamt Studie
lesen irgendwann kommt man dann zu einem
Wert wo man ganz vergessen
warum haben Sie eigentlich im Jahr davor
auf 1,5 Millionen also das
Umweltbundesamt
macht seit sechs Jahren jedes Jahr ein
neues Studio kommt immer zu neuen
Ergebnissen also da wäre ich sehr
vorsichtig was diese Studienergebnisse
angeht aber ich habe eine Idee und auch
Sie der Mitglied einer Partei die 2011
den endgültigen Ausstieg aus der
Kernenergie beschlossen hat wenn wir
über dieses Thema reden CO2 Vermeidung
beispielsweise und sichere Strom sichere
Stromerzeugung wenn wir auch über die
Frage reden wir sollen E-Autos die
einigermaßen günstig auch fahren und
aufgeladen werden in diesem Land fahren
lassen dann ist das Thema weniger CO2 in
der Luft und das mit Kernkraft zu
koppeln 1 was quasi auf der Hand liegt
und da ist es auch was die
Glaubwürdigkeit der CDU angeht nicht
ganz redlich immer zu sagen wir müssen
hier noch beim Mühe beim Autofahrer dann
noch sagen
wir ähm und sagen das Tempolimit ist es
jetzt wenn Italien sogar aufgeht und das
Klima wird immer global gedacht zu Recht
in China zwei Kohlekraftwerke pro Woche
neu ans Netz gehen dann können wir hier
sparen und sparen dass wir wollen falsch
so viel Energie und Wind Energie wie
China die wollen ja jetzt sogar den
Solar Export verbieten weil sie selber
braucht so viel Kohlekraftwerke
china baut noch zu viele Kohlekraftwerke
aber Zulassung zwei pro Woche aber wir
können doch nicht sie können doch nicht
also erstens ich bin ja habe ich ja
vorhin schon gesagt ich bin ja für die
Verlängerung der bestehenden nur die
bringen also wir können die drei die wir
noch haben verlängern
die ähm wir können doch nicht sagen der
Verkehr verlagert das nämlich das was
die Bundesregierung jetzt macht am Ende
wird die Industrie den Preis zahlen wir
werden aber mehr Arbeitslosigkeit
kriegen weil wir werden die Klimaziele
nur einhalten können wir die
industrialisieren das ist der dann der
de facto Weg alles andere ist wir werden
ja wieder bei den Gebäuden vor innerhalb
von 20 Jahren alle Heizung austauschen
noch wird die Landwirtschaft das Liefern
also wird die Industrie liefern müssen
und wenn es die Industrie liefert weil
wir das im Verkehr nicht machen dann
müssen wir nur wissen was wir tun dann
sitzen dann ist die Autoindustrie erst
richtig betroffen deswegen hatte ich das
für Unsinn und Sie können das ist
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich sie frage was
wollen sie im Verkehr tun sagen sie
Atomkraftwerke
aber
der Klimaschutz macht doch keinen
Unterschied zwischen Sektor der sagt
doch nicht weil in der Industrie mehr
eingespart wurde und im Verkehr weniger
als
geplant im Verkehr
weil wir mehr Autos fahren und größere
Autos fahren und mehr Kilometer fahren
ja auch wo die Bevölkerung gar nicht so
sehr steigt nicht brechen dann haben wir
Probleme Unterstützung haben Sie denn in
der eigenen Partei wenn Sie jetzt mit
Friedrich Merz beispielsweise was
Tempolimit sprechen
ist dafür noch nicht die Klima AG also
die die sich von morgens bis abends mit
Kindern und Energie beschäftigen die die
sind mehrheitlich dafür also eine kleine
AG ist dafür
Arbeitsgruppen Fachgruppen und die
Fachgruppe in der Bundestagsfraktion für
Klima und Energie ist dafür mehrheitlich
aber
in der Partei ist es noch keine mehr
aber ich mache das ja nicht weil sie
Wahrheit ist oder weil es die Grünen
sagen sondern weiß für seiner Sache
richtig
meinen Kindern ehrlich gesagt nicht eine
überhitzte Erde da stellen ich glaube
Leute haben keine Ahnung was das
wirklich heißt das klingt ja immer so
wenig hier in Berlin wo wir gerade sind
war vor
20.000 Jahren die Temperaturen nur vier
Grad kälter aber wir hatten 200 Meter
Eis die Nordsee gab es nicht England war
keine Insel die Ostsee war ein kleines
Binnengewässer das machen wir gerade aus
damit man sich einfach mal vorstellt was
das für dramatische Veränderungen sind
die werden so teuer werden 3 Milliarden
Menschen der Welt haben die nicht da
wohnen bleiben können wo sie heute
wohnen das wird alles so viel Geld
kosten jetzt nicht sagen naja also ich
habe irgendwie passt uns beides nicht
vor Spritpreis nicht und ja 120 nicht
aber wir lassen diese Gefahren
die Wahrheit sagen dass wir leider in
Deutschland die Klimaziele auch im
letzten Jahr erreicht hat müssen wir
einfach das wird immer so getan das
leider werden so
20% Rückgang in der Industrie hatten
wegen des Ukraine Kriegs ohne die wäre
die Klimaziele locker gerissen worden
und im Verkehr an der Gebäude haben wir
sie alle wieder gerissen aber sie haben
doch gerade
so dass wenn du zuhörst dass du nichts
ein Mensch da ist ja die Ampel fast
besser ist wenn
äh schwarz grün kommt ich glaube dass
der die Sektor Einteilung nicht ganz
nicht ganz richtig ist weil Klima wie
wir wissen auch in Europa ja nicht vor
der deutschen Landesgrenze Grenze Halt
macht und wenn in Polen Kohle verfeuert
wird dann ist das insgesamt für die
Verschmutzung schlecht aber nicht für
die deutsche Luft alleine und die
polnische Luft sondern das ist ja ein
globales Problem und insofern ist es
glaube ich tut man sich nicht unbedingt
einen Gefallen wenn man Sektor Ziele
macht das glaube ich zumindest die Frage
ist weicht man sie auf die Frage ist
wollen wir Fahrverbote hinnehmen
beispielsweise wollen wir wie sie sagen
der Industrie mehr zumuten das sind
alles Dinge die kann man diskutieren und
man muss sich glaube ich immer der
Folgekosten am Ende bewusst sein ich
finde zum Beispiel einen bestätigen
Anstieg was Benzinpreise angeht durchaus
in Ordnung weil es den Menschen die
Freiheit sozusagen nein auf vier Euro
von 4€ hat aber im nächsten Jahr auch
niemand gesprochen ich weiß nicht ob sie
das wollen aber der CO2-Anstieg so wie
er geplant ist der Aufschlag bedeutet ja
nicht der Liter für Euro aber ich sage
Ihnen auch was anderes das was jetzt
passiert mit den Wärmepumpen so wie es
aufgesetzt ist das ist doch kein Wort
billiger wenn Robert Habeck verspricht
die soziale Abfederung soll so laufen
dass der Einbau einer neuen Wärmepumpe
25 bis 30.000 € genauso teuer ist wieder
Einbau einer neuen gastheizung 7 bis
8000 €. dann reden wir hier bei kleine
mittleren Einkommen über Budgets von 20
bis 25000 €. die der Steuerzahler
finanzieren muss pro Haushalt oder
Autoverkehr weil sie gerade sagen das
wäre auch ob ich das möchte dass Benzin
so teuer wird die die Frage ist doch die
Kosten entstehen so und so und jetzt ist
nur die Frage mache ich es
planwirtschaftlich planwirtschaftlich
indem ich per Bewohner die kriegt
Befehle was zu tun ist oder mache ich es
lasse ich den Menschen die Freiheit zu
sagen ich stoße jetzt mein Auto weil mir
das nach und nach zu teuer wird oder ich
kaufe mir lieber jetzt eine neue Heizung
weil mir das und das zu teuer wird also
befehle ich das oder gebe ich den
Menschen rein und da wäre mein Einsatz
immer zu sagen ich mache das gebt den
Menschen die Freiheit selbst zu
entscheiden wenn man sich zu viel
streitet ist vielleicht auf jeden Fall
mal der Punkt sich zu trennen das geht
zum Glück nicht für diese Runde hier wir
machen nur eine ganz kurze Pause dann
sind wir gleich zurück reden über dieses
Thema und auch über die Rundfunkgebühren
bis gleich
[Musik]
und da sind wir wieder zurück bei
viertel nach acht schönen dass Sie bei
uns sind ja Schlagzeilen wie diese
bringen viele Menschen wirklich in
Aufruhr der frühere Vize Internat
hagenbranstädter der möchte jetzt ein
jährliches Ruhegeld von
150.000 Euro das für seine Arbeit beim
rbb und die Rundfunkgebühren die könnten
eventuell auch noch steigen das sagen
sie ist wirklich jeder Euro zu viel
ja also seit dem letzten Sommer ist ja
im öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk nicht
mehr das was es mal war weil es hat
natürlich die Leute empört die das
Skandal rund um den RBB und ähm
eigentlich müsste man jetzt denken da
ist jetzt ein bisschen Demut oder
Bescheidenheit angesagt und jetzt haben
unsere Recherchen herausbekommen das ist
nein es gibt sozusagen die Pläne sollen
jetzt so dahin gehen erweitert werden
dass diese Gebühren sogar steigen werden
momentan zahlt jeder Deutsche 18 Euro 36
und aus diesen internen Unterlagen
wissen wir dass das über 20 Euro gehen
soll die ARD will sozusagen noch mehr
Rundfunkgebühren erheben und das ist
natürlich etwas wo man sagen muss guckt
doch erstmal wo sind die Gelder jetzt
hingegangen was ist an Verschwendung da
was kann gestoppt werden und deswegen
bin ich dafür diese Gebühren nicht zu
erhöhen es bedeutet aber auch die
Gebühren nicht erhöhen das bedeutet die
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen die müssten an
der ein oder anderen Stelle dann
Einsparungen auch Treffen das heißt was
kann weg was soll vielleicht auch weg
ich finde es erstmal interessant zu
gucken was ist denn überhaupt jetzt wo
sind die großen Kosten und sie hatten es
ja eben schon angesprochen es geht ja um
riesige Gehälter und Pensionen z.B wenn
man sich vorstellt dass die frühere
Intendantin Patricia Schlesinger jetzt
ein Pensionsanspruch vor Gericht
erstreiten will von 18000 € im Monat das
ist ja unvorstellbar damit liegt sie
über der Kanzlerin und so einem System
muss ja kann ja irgendetwas nicht
stimmen wenn so viel Geld für Pensionen
da ist und die neue rbb intendante die
dann die Nachfolgerin geworden ist die
hat ja gesagt wir müssen jetzt sparen
und wir sparen am Programm das ist
natürlich das ärgerliche und ich finde
man muss jetzt erstmal schauen wie ist
die Kostenstruktur wie sind überhaupt es
ist ja auch überhaupt gar keine
Transparenz da was kosten denn so
samstags Abendshows mit Florian
Silbereisen habe ich nicht als
Gebührenzahler auch ein Recht darauf das
zu erfahren weil als Steuerzahler weiß
ich ganz genau was ein
Bundestagsabgeordneter kostet und was
bestimmte
Vorhaben Kosten das kriege ich ja beim
öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk nicht
mit und ich finde es eine sehr spannende
Debatte die dieser ganze rbb Skandal
ausgelöst hat da sind wir jetzt gerade
mittendrin und ich glaube diese Debatte
muss auch offen und ehrlich geführt
werden und das geht nicht wenn sozusagen
die ARD-Intendanten jetzt schon wieder
Lobby ihren um die Rundfunkgebühren dann
in der nächsten Periode auf bis zu 25 €
zu erhöhen und immer wieder gibt es
Diskussionen seit Jahren schon muss man
sagen ja um Reformen aber die finden
irgendwie in die Stadt der Bremse aus
also zumindest bremsen die Intendanten
auch selbst das haben wir ja gesehen als
tomburow im vergangenen Jahr als wir die
er-chef ard-chef zum Ende seiner
Amtszeit
Vorschläge gemacht hat wie man den
öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk
reformieren könnte und eigentlich seinen
eigenen Leuten auch ziemlich ins
Gewissen geredet hat und dann ja auch
vom jetzt designierten oder jetzt
amtierenden ard-chef kein kniffke sehr
sehr schnell eigentlich gesagt bekommen
hat nee nee so wollen wir mal nicht
vorgehen also ähm das System vielleicht
können Sie auch noch mehr sagen dass wir
einmal das ist natürlich auch von
Politikern mit kontrolliert ist ein
System der Abhängigkeiten in
Rundfunkgeräten sitzen Politiker die die
intenden kontrollieren sollen die
Intendanten kontrollieren aber auf der
anderen Seite mit ihren Medien Marken
natürlich auch die Politik also
Abhängigkeitsverhältnis von oben nach
unten wieder nach oben oder nach unten
je nachdem wie man dreht und in dieser
verschachtelten Abhängigkeit sind
Reformen automatisch werden
mal direkt weiter wie groß ist der
Einfluss der Politik auf die öffentlich
rechtlichen Medien wie viel Interesse
hat man daran da auf seine Macht zu
manifestieren das hat nichts gemacht zu
tun sondern
wir haben halt viele unabhängige
Institutionen den Eigenleben führen die
Bundesbank ja auch da finden wir das
alle gut dass sie unabhängig sind und
die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen rundfunken
geben ein Drittel ihres Budgets
inzwischen für Pensionslasten aus da
gibt es jetzt nicht nur den Extremfall
den sie gerade geschildert haben den ich
auch skandalös finde sondern ein Drittel
des Geldes ist weg vertraglich
zugesichert und können wir jetzt den
pensionierten Rentnern aus dem
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk sagen
unsere Verträge nicht schwierige Frage
und wir Politiker das soll ja staatsfern
sein deswegen sollen wir uns ja nicht
einmischen der Einfluss der Politik ist
in den rumfokarten rückläufig für ihn
auch richtig dass das nicht Politiker
Mensch jetzt schon Partei Buch oder ja
es gibt auch viele die keinen Partei
buchen und die
also man darf sich das überhaupt nicht
so vorstellen Intendant kann da nicht
von der Relation anrufen so wie jetzt
auch Matthias töpfner nicht bei Ihnen
anrufen kann sagen
wenn man dem Hallmann die Frage nicht
oder stellt sich gerade oder so
funktioniert das System nicht und so
wird das auch dann nicht funktionieren
aber die die Wahrheit ist wir müssen uns
durchringen zu einer Strukturreform
sonst werden die Kosten immer weiter
steigen und deswegen ist es natürlich
sehr wohlfalt jetzt eine Nullrunde zu
fahren bin gleich dagegen aber das
größte strukturelle Problem nicht wir
müssen irgendwelche Entscheidungen
treffen nämlich welche Sendungen sollen
abgeschafft werden welche Sender sollen
abgeschafft werden brauchen wir nur
einen öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
diese Debatte müssen wir in Deutschland
führen und die sollten eigentlich die
sollten ein sollte eigentlich die
Gesellschaft führen und nicht die
Politik entscheiden weil das nämlich so
aussieht wir wollen einen kontrolliert
weniger haben weil es jetzt einen Sender
bei der ARD weniger gibt ich finde das
ist nicht unsere Aufgabe sondern diese
Debatte insofern hat tomorro völlig
recht er muss diese Debatte oder
Menschen wie tempure müssen sie führen
und ich hoffe sie kommt Richtlinien vor
die Debatte kommt in Schwung wir hatten
hier auch eine Mitarbeiterin vom ZDF
Katrin Seibert die hat nämlich schon
gesagt es wird tatsächlich einiges von
oben runter diktiert daher er ist ganz
normal die Frage an Sie wie groß ist
schon gesagt was was
sagen sie hat gesagt er wurde schon auch
Themen vorgegeben ihr wurde schon auch
eine Richtung vorgegeben ich möchte nur
die Frage vor allem in die kommentieren
nichts an den Kostenproblem unter dem
Strukturproblem das jetzt stimmt was ich
nicht bestätigen kann aber ich weiß wir
haben ein Strukturproblem und wir wir
das ist wie immer in Deutschland man
will alles haben aber irgendwie die
Kosten nicht bezahlen so geht's nicht ja
also wir müssen uns schon entscheiden
wenn wir sagen wir wollen weniger
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk müssen
noch ein bisschen sagen wo wir ihn
weniger haben wollen ja das ist alles
behalten
ich glaube der Einfluss der Politik der
ist gar nicht mehr so groß wie früher
mal war aber wirklich so dass es hieß in
Bayern musste und halten csu-partei Buch
haben in NRW brauchst du einen
SPD-Parteibuch das ist zurückgegangen
was halt sehr stark vorangegangen ist
ist dieser ganze Apparat dieser
Verwaltungsapparat der da entstanden ist
mit den ganzen
Landesrundfunkanstalten mit immer mehr
Sendern und ich fand es auch interessant
dass es sehr viele Mitarbeiter zum
Beispiel vom rbb gegeben hat dass wir
diese Recherchen im letzten Sommer
gemacht haben die uns Dankesbriefe
geschickt haben die gesagt haben gut
dass ihr darüber berichtet habt dass
diese Führung Weg ist weil wir uns
wieder auf unsere Arbeit vielleicht auch
mehr konzentrieren können weil man muss
ja auch ehrlicherweise sagen es gibt da
ja auch wirklich sehr gute Kollegen und
sehr gute Sendungen die da gemacht
werden Dokumentation Reportagen die
Frage ist halt es Ufer hat halt immer
mehr aus und ähm ich erwarte eigentlich
jetzt auch von der ARD dass sie mal
Vorschläge machen brauche ich denn da
diese ganzen spatensender beispielsweise
brauche ich diesen
Verwaltungsapparat der da ist und muss
man nicht auch einfach bei diesen
Pensionslasten da wirklich auch mal den
Rotstift ansetzen wo würde man da
vielleicht können wir mal versuchen den
Rotstift auch anzusetzen ja was braucht
man bei den öffentlich rechtlichen
findest du man könnte vielleicht ein
Sender daraus machen braucht man Sport
braucht man Unterhaltung braucht man nur
Informationssendungen wie könnte denn so
eine Reform aussehen also
Grundversorgung so ist es ja definiert
braucht sicherlich nicht so viele Sender
wie wir jetzt derzeit haben wenn man in
den Norden guckt beispielsweise es gibt
allein vier Programme des NDR dazu die
regionalen Programme plus dann in den
fünf vier Bundesländer sind noch mal
Regionalprogramm also sie sind dann bei
acht Radiosendern allein so und das gibt
es natürlich im Bundesländer in Bayern
hat glaube ich allein fünf verschiedene
Radioprogramme wer eins bis fünf also es
ist einfach ein wie
es gerade schon gesagt hat ein Wildwuchs
entstanden und ich glaube hier gibt es
auch wenn es da ganz ganz viele tolle
Kollegen gibt natürlich viel Spaß
Potenzial und ich bin jetzt nicht in der
Position zu sagen die Millionen müssen
alle weg aber wenn wir uns anschauen was
in Österreich passiert ist dann ist dort
hat es jetzt wird es jetzt eine Reform
geben in Österreich und ähm die
Österreicher machen es wie in
Deutschland sie gehen von einer
haushaltsgebühr quasi auf eine
gerätegebühr über also jeder Haushalt
muss ich auf einer Gerät über eine
haushaltsgebühren
zahlen das heißt die Zahl der
derjenigen die jetzt überhaupt zahlen
müssen steigt um 400.000 aber
gleichzeitig sinkt die Gebühr von ich
glaube ungefähr 22 Euro um ungefähr ein
Drittel auf 15 Euro bedeutet ein
deutlicher eine deutliche Reduktion für
alle die bisher so eine Gebirge gezahlt
haben das hat es in Deutschland wir
haben diese Umstellung auch gehabt aber
es hat diese Reduzierung nie gegeben und
einhergeht ja in Österreich auch ein
Appell zu sparen und das hat eigentlich
so bei uns in Deutschland bisher in
dieser Dimension nicht gegeben und wenn
die Frage so an mich gerichtet würde ich
sagen versuchen wir doch sowieso
Österreich gemacht haben die
Grundvoraussetzungen haben wir schon
aber den Beitrag doch mal um rund ein
Drittel vielleicht zu reduzieren und
dann muss man sehen wie man mit den
Kosten oder mit den Einnahmen die es
gibt umgeht und welche Programme dann
noch überlebensfähig sind und welche
nicht spannendes Thema vielleicht kommt
es mal zu einer Reform vielleicht werden
die Programme die Inhalte umgestaltet
mit regionalen fensternis liegen ja
immer auch wieder Ideen auf dem Tisch
ich habe gerade schon gesagt manchmal
ist es einfach Zeit zu gehen dann ist
dieser Zeitpunkt eigentlich gekommen wie
steht's und unser Herz wie stets um
unsere Beziehungen ja um vier von fünf
steht nicht unbedingt gut da sollte man
vielleicht gehen das sagt Bestseller
Autor Thomas Meyer jetzt bei uns in der
Sendung
ja danke ich bin der Ansicht dass die
meisten Paare unglücklich sind in ihren
Beziehungen und diese auflösen sollten
die sollten sich trennen aber die
Trennung hat dann immens schlechtes
Image deswegen bleiben all die
Betroffenen oder die meisten davon halt
da drin stehen und leiden weiter
worunter vor allem ihre Kinder am
meisten leiden
und ich sehe hier die Einblendung den
die Deutschen sind beziehungsgestört
habe ich so nie gesagt ich weiß nicht
welche wohl war jene das da reingetextet
hat vielleicht können Sie das erklären
trennt euch also zum einen sie können
auch sagen weltweit sind wir alle
Beziehungsgespräch
sehr schlecht wenn das Schweizer hier
einfliegt und was was so schlimm ist
über die Deutschen sagt also es betrifft
nicht nur uns ist nein ich habe auch ein
Buch zu dem Thema geschrieben das heißt
trennt euch und wenn ich darf lese ich
kurz vor was da drin hinten drauf steht
erstens es passt oder es passt nicht
zweitens meistens passt es nicht
drittens wenn es nicht passt wird es nie
passen viertens wenn es nicht passt
leiden sie fünftens wenn sie leiden
müssen sie gehen und sechstens das Leben
ist sehr kurz das habe ich 2017
publiziert und seither ganz viel
erhalten und das hat zu einer neuen
Tätigkeit geführt nämlich die
Trennungsberatung damit bin ich heute
hier und nicht nur für die Deutschen
sondern für alle genau für alle für die
ganze Welt für die weltheit genau nicht
nur die deutschen das klingt natürlich
aber auch so ein bisschen danach dass es
sich nicht lohnt zu kämpfen und ich
glaube zu Ihnen kommen natürlich auch
viele Menschen die sagen ich kämpfe
schon so lange wann ist denn der Punkt
aus ihrer Sicht wo man sagen sollte
lohnt sich nicht lass sein mit dem
Kämpfen ja also die Wortwahl schon das
Wort kämpfen beinhaltet dann ist schon
mal nicht so gut würde ich sagen aber
die Frage wann ist denn genug die wird
mir oft gestellt und ich ich würde sagen
wenn in einem Monat mehr als drei vier
Tage von von Streit und Missstimmung und
und Frustration und Aggression geprägt
sind dann ist seit mal zumindest offen
darüber zu sprechen auch ergebnisoffen
das ist die Frage wie oft haben Sie sich
schon getrennt man könnte dann denken
dass sie sich
laufenden Schnürchen quasi getrennt habe
ich tatsächlich also mir wird ja oft
vorgehalten dass meine längste Beziehung
lediglich vier Jahre gedauert habe und
ich somit gar nichts zum Thema zu sagen
hätte das ist natürlich eine
Fehleinschätzung denn ich sage ja nicht
beziehungsexperte sondern
trennungsexperte und in dieser Funktion
ja ich glaube ich habe sicher was soll
ich denn sagen 15 Trennungen oder so was
durchlebt auf der einen wir auf der
anderen Seite ich habe aber vor allem
halt mehrere Beziehungen gehabt und
rundherum auch Beziehungen erlebt und
oft erlebt dass die Menschen wirklich
unglücklich sind auch offen darüber
sprechen
leidenschaftlich darüber sprechen und
wenn man dann fragt ganz
unverhohlen ja warum trennst du dich
denn nicht dann kippt das ganze und dann
werden lauter wirklich nicht sehr gute
Gründe genannt warum das doch
weitergeführt werden muss und der
populärste ist natürlich wieder wegen
der Kinder zusammen und warum lassen Sie
das quasi nicht gelten weil wenn eine
Beziehung auch schon so weit ist und
damit meine ich nicht gut weiß sondern
so kaputt ist dass man nur noch wegen
der Kinder zusammenbleibt dann ist das
für die ja wohl nicht förderlich denn
wir Eltern sind unseren Kindern Vorbild
und wenn wir ständig streiten und nicht
mehr liebevoll sind zueinander und und
einander nicht mehr achten dann sind wir
auch darin an Vorbild für unsere Kinder
und es ist ja oft so dass Menschen die
unglücklich sind in ihren Beziehungen
die sagen ich mache eigentlich genau das
gleiche was meine Eltern schon gemacht
haben und das ist weil die Eltern das
vorgelebt haben schau so ist Beziehung
so ist Kommunikation so ist Nähe und
wenn man diesen Kreis brechen will dann
soll man sich spätestens an dem Punkt
drinnen wo man sagt das ist jetzt nur
noch wegen der Kinder so wie erfolgreich
sind sie in ihren Beratungen kommen dann
die Menschen und gehen dann auch
ziemlich schnell getrennt wieder raus
oder wie läuft das als die Frage wie man
hier den Erfolg
wenn ich den Erfolg dran Messe ob
bedeutet das tun was sie tun sollten
dann bin ich sehr erfolglos ich in
diesem Coachings die ich anbiete ist es
aber mein Ziel den Menschen auch zu
zeigen was die Kosten des Bleibens sind
und was die Kosten des Gehens sind also
das eine Trennung Konsequenzen hat ist
allen klar die sind auch alle scheiße
muss man so sagen ich verstehe dass man
da davor zurückschreckt aber bleiben hat
er auch einen Preis nämlich da wird man
echt krank also ich spreche mit Leuten
die haben wirklich bereits körperliche
Erscheinungen die Blase die Augen die
Schulter also man wird da wirklich krank
man macht sich und die Kinder krank in
einer schlechten Beziehung das ist eine
Tatsache wann kann die Beziehung halten
was ist eine gute Beziehung sehen sie
Menschen wo sie sagen ja das ist
wirklich über eine irgendwie hängen wir
alle an dem Traum für immer und immer
viele schwören sich das bis dass der Tod
euch scheidet das gehen viele noch eines
versprechen sehen Sie Menschen die
zusammen passen wo sie auch sagen das
ist wichtig das braucht eine Liebe eine
Beziehung sie lange hält ja damit wir
uns richtig verstehen auch kompatible
Partnerinnen die gibt es ja und auch die
stehen vor Herausforderungen also wir
alle haben Meinungsverschiedenheiten
auch wenn wir einander wirklich zugetan
sind und und sehr ähnlich sind in der
Ideologie und dem Humor und so weiter
auch da gibt es Brücken zu schlagen und
Hindernisse zu überwinden ist klar aber
ich sehe halt und das geht auch mich an
ich habe das auch sehr lange so gehalten
wir lernen jemanden kennen finden die
Person super toll dann ist das noch
gegenseitig und dann geht's ab ins Bett
und dann hat man eine Beziehung und erst
dann lernt man ja die Person wirklich
kennen und das machen ja die frommen
Juden und Jüdinnen machen da sehr viel
klüger die treffen sich erst zu einem
sogenannten Schädel das ist eine
Heiratsvermittlung und da wird bevor
irgendwas läuft wird diskutiert wie
hältst du es mit der Politik wie was
sind deine Werte wie erziehst du wie
willst du deine Kinder ziehen und wenn
man da merkt oh nicht die Unterschiede
zu groß dann sagt man vielen Dank und
sucht weiter und vermählt sich erst wenn
man sagen kann dass es ein stabiles
Fundament alle anderen sollten das auch
so tun also bewerten wir das verliebt
sein verknallt sein ein bisschen über ja
total also lieber ist komplett
überschätzt ohne geht es ja ist schon
klar ist eine tolle Sache aber
wir das kennen wir alle wir verlieben
uns mal so mal so das ist eine sehr
hormonelle spontane Angelegenheit die ja
wirklich eigentlich ein Trugschluss ist
also wenn ich mich jetzt in den Herrn
Schäfer verliebe dann dann weiß ich ja
nicht wer das ist ich kann den super
attraktiv finden aber ich weiß nicht wie
der Text und wenn wir dann paar sind
dann merke ich auch scheiße das ist aber
gar nicht so wie gedacht aber ich möchte
ja dass es klappt und dann beginnt
dieser schreckliche Machtkampf der
sozusagen
[Gelächter]
was glaubst Du dieses Streben nach der
Romantik nach der Liebe für immer ist es
im Prinzip so ein kleines Auslaufmodell
ich merke hier am Tisch und es tut uns
auch allen so ein bisschen so alles
landen wir über hier auf dem Boden der
Realität muss man das vielleicht sind
wir vielleicht alle ein bisschen über
romantisiert ich weiß nicht wenn ich mir
die Scheidungszahlen anschaue glaube ich
das ist viele Menschen gibt zumindest in
Deutschland in der Schweiz mag das
ähnlich sein die für sich ganz klar ja
auch sagen wir wir trennen uns also
selbst nicht so dass die
Scheidungszahlen in den letzten Jahren
besonders rückläufig gewesen sind viel
zu tief sie sind gut okay
das heißt ja nicht dass die anderen 50%
super glücklich sind nein das weiß auch
sondern tendenziell super feige wenn ich
jetzt okay vielleicht ist es auch so die
also passt man aus ihrer Sicht passt man
gar nicht zusammen nicht ich habe da
eine andere wieso nicht gesagt die 50%
zu niedrig und 50%, die anderen sind zu
feige
bin ich zu naiv wie auch immer
ganz deutlich zu machen nicht in der
Politik aber im privaten und ich glaube
das ist ja auch lebenslange
Freundschaften beispielsweise in der
Regel gibt es das eine tolle Sache keine
Frage aber
zu nichts führt also gerade in der
Politik weiß man das ja ein Problem muss
auch mal gelöst werden sonst ist es
offenbar unlösbar und wenn eine
Beziehung sich nur immer um die gleichen
Dinge dreht und sich nie was ändert und
bessert dann ist die Grundlage wohl faul
in der Politik kennt man das ihre Partei
eher konservativ erhält man vielleicht
noch an so Konzepten wie die Ehe und die
ist für immer das ist ein Versprechen
fest und denkt sich ja meine Güte was
erzählt er den Moment mal liebe gibt's
nicht und man passt nicht zusammen wie
geht es ihnen in der Diskussion haben
dann meine eigene private Umgebung
gecheckt ich habe wir haben da komme ich
aber locker nicht auf 50% Scheidung
sondern viel weniger
sind die 80%, die da zusammen bleiben ob
die alle unglücklich sind nicht meine
Beobachtung aber vielleicht ist auch
nicht repräsentativ man kann
durchhalten wollen wir haben viele
Aufgaben die wir mehr recht als schlecht
hinkriegen ich finde privaten Politiker
habe ich den Bund zu halten
Verbrauch das schon eher das ist sicher
eine sehr schlechte Beziehung da das
kann man gerade nach den Gäste
das ist ja der entscheidende Punkt sie
sind ja trennungsbereit
politische Klienten nehmen das ist ja
die Frage
romantische Liebe ein für immer glauben
Sie daran ja ich bin fest davon
überzeugt also ich glaube schon dass die
die Hemmschwelle zur Trennung heutzutage
nicht mehr so groß ist wie es vielleicht
in der Elterngeneration war da hat man
dann eher noch mal so zusammengehalten
und ich gebe aber den Traum von der
ewigen Liebe nicht auf und möchte mich
eigentlich in meinem Leben nicht mehr
drin
er gibt nicht auf den Traum aber das ist
auch kein aber ich finde das toll ich
gebe ihn auch nicht auf dass das Zeus
geben und gibt es auch es gibt Menschen
die zusammenpassen und miteinander eine
schöne Beziehung führen genau
am besten trennen könnte wenn sie sich
trennen möchte oder
soll sie sich denn trennen also ich
meine man hat da jetzt doch ein Vertrag
unterschrieben und da gibt's eine
Legislaturperiode und so weiter wann ist
der Punkt zu gehen ich finde es ja ganz
schön wenn man die gemeinsame Ziele
verfolgen würde
zusammen die Ampel soll zusammen bleiben
aber die Zuschauer sollen sich treffen
ungewöhnliche Konsequenz sagen wir mal
so ich denke das ist schon ein
Unterschied ob da eine private Beziehung
geführt wird oder Polizei zu tun ja also
ich fasse zusammen die Unglücklichen die
sollten sich treffen sollen sich fragen
warum sie unglücklich sind und sie hier
unglücklich sein eingestehen und den Mut
finden sich zu trennen es ist nämlich
nur halb so schlimm das ist glaube ich
ein trösten das Wort für viele die
unglücklich sind und auch wir trennen
uns jetzt obwohl wir glücklich sind in
dieser Runde das kann ich zumindest
sagen zusammenpassen
vielen herzlichen Dank an meine Gäste
und vielen herzlichen Dank an sie das
war für 8:15
[Musik]